you can just imagine someone with a
hundred percent creativity and zero
percent productivity they might have the
most brilliant imagination and ideas and
no one would ever know and it won't ever
matter because not one piece of work
will be finished and then you have
someone full productivity no creativity
they're basically a machine just
churning out identical widgets
productivity is about getting it done
creativity is about getting it right
tiago forte welcome to the show it's
great to be here chris it's been a while
three and a half years it's been
a very long while
yeah i'm excited to i don't
in fact i very rarely do follow-up
episodes so i'm glad we can have a part
two me too are you would you consider
yourself the new david allen now of 2022
so other people have said that i i try
to be modest but i mean that's my that's
my aspiration to be honest if i can make
even half the impact he made on the
world i'd be i'd go to my grave happy
why why is he a hero
i think just the way he did it
there's a lot of thought leaders a lot
of productivity authors a lot of people
who created methodologies but
i think the fact that he he took it to
its full potential
i think is the main thing it's so it
would be so easy to just write one book
after another sort of roam around to
different subjects make a name for
yourself
but he just spent decade upon decade
really just
translating his principles into every
format
every medium every channel to really
make sure it reached you know the ends
of the earth and i just admire that kind
of persistence on one thing because
because it's so important for people the
fact that people still use the gtd
method
30 years
after he first wrote about it i think
kind of
shows the test of time so given the fact
that you're someone who spends a lot of
time thinking about systems and
productivity and stuff like that
how do you and how can other people
avoid obsessing over productivity too
much because
looking at productivity can become a
task in it like a sisyphean task in
itself and you can end up being super
unproductive because of your constant
obsession about tools and techniques and
tactics
yeah it's a great question it can easily
become a hobby it can become a lifestyle
right
so the way i think of this is
productivity is a phase
there's a career in there there's a
phase in your career
in your job in your business where you
should obsess about pro about
productivity you should just make it as
efficient as possible
but then it's productivity it's like
reading and writing and arithmetic it's
this
this foundational fundamental layer
right like like if you don't have just
the basic ability to like say you're
gonna do something and then do it to
just
clearly go from step one to step two to
step three which is what productivity is
nothing else you do no other source of
leverage is going to work for you you
don't have to perfect it you don't have
to take it to 10 level 10 just get to
like level six or seven
and then you move on to essentially
higher sources of leverage which are
creativity which are management
leadership
uh creating content leveraging systems
like there's all these things that are
much
higher order but that you need that
basic personal productivity to take
advantage of yeah i like that i think um
a lot of the time when we're thinking
about the stuff that we do in life and
the tasks that we have in front of us
and the um personal development that
we're doing we look at what we're
working on now and forget that we're
going to complete that at some point or
at least i do my time discounting
basically doesn't exist and i just see
an endless
let's say that i'm working on my
overhead position in the gym or
i'm learning the pomodoro technique or
something that's it that's me for the
rest of time but it's not it's not you
you're right the analogy is precisely
correct between arithmetic or learning
maths or learning something in school
right you don't go back and learn what
two plus two equals now it's there you
now are able to build off the back of
that knowledge so if you were to say uh
if you were to create a high level
uh syllabus or if you were to just pick
the main things that people need to know
what would uh your productivity driver's
license what would it consist of
yeah it's great
i i really like thinking about this
because people always want to know the
maximalist
most sophisticated powerful advanced
version
minimum viable productivity system
all the way i mean in school
you know a c 70 is passing just try to
pass
uh i would really point people to code
the methodology which is the the heart
of my book and my everything i teach
and the important thing is to realize
it's not a tool it's an is it's an
activity
so you need some way that the four
letters of code capture organize distill
express you need some way of capturing
it doesn't have to look any particular
way it could be writing on your arm it
could be capturing voice memos it could
be bookmarking websites there's just so
many ways just have one just one
reliable way to capture content you're
great right organize which i would just
say is some way of organizing that
content it doesn't have to be my para
approach doesn't have to be by category
does definitely shouldn't be very
meticulous but some way of adding
structure to your notes
and then the same for distill some way
of distilling some way of expressing
it's almost like there's an analogy here
to personal finance in personal finance
you need to earn
you need to spend you need to save and
you need to invest
right everyone for the most part
who is beyond the most basic needs is
doing those four things but
i don't think most people would say oh i
have a personal financial system this is
my personal financial workflow no they
just kind of generally know that those
four things are happening
somewhere in their lives and that's
enough to live a financially successful
life same goes for knowledge
why do
why does anyone need a second brain
yeah
it's funny
i often tell people you don't
and this is actually a good little
accountability is
whatever you're trying to do like
writing or podcasting or building a
business there's someone out there
someone out there many people who are
doing that without a second brain
like obviously right
there are people writing books with no
particular note-taking system people
building incredible businesses having
the relationships they want to have
reaching their goals so it's not so much
like a lot of
self-improvement authors or people with
a system will say no
all of your success your entire future
rests
on this thing and i i have to just be
honest and say like a second brain is
kind of optional
um
but what i would say is for certain
people in certain situations who are
people who have to deal with a lot of
information who have to make sense of
that information and make decisions on
it who have to create things whether
content or events or proposals or slides
if there's some kind of creative output
you will save unimaginable amounts of
time energy
headache stress and have just much
greater peace of mind it with a more a
second brain is really just a more
rigorous approach to doing those things
that you're already doing
is there a danger when you start to do
the second brain thing which i've been
familiar with for three or four years i
think since i first read your blog post
on it
one of the guys i'm very good friends
with youssef basically became addicted
to indexing information
um he saw
any potentially entertaining or useful
thing
that he ever consumed or heard on the
radio or whatever
as fodder to be put into his personal
knowledge management system so
given that the sort of people that are
going to be attracted to building a
second brain are probably the kind of
people that already have a
predisposition to like indexing
information and not forgetting cool
stuff that they've learned or may want
to use in future
what is a good way for someone to temper
that
um
propensity
yeah i feel like those people is me
you are these people yeah i mean that
that's that's my whole audience that's
my that's my target market
uh i mean if there was someone out there
and there are many people who have no
interest propensity or desire to do this
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you know
imagine me working with like an elite
athlete or artist or musician being like
okay you need to set aside you know your
craft you really need to sit here at
your computer and just like take notes
on things
[Music]
i'm basically talking to people who
can't help but take notes can't help who
their the organization of their digital
life is actually the roadblock from a
like a psychological point of view they
can't move forward because of the
clutter and the disorder
um so if you're that kind of person
what i would say is
to just shift
how you're spending your time from
consumption to creation right like this
is this is a very powerful exercise just
look at the time that you spend this can
be very ballpark what percentage of say
your time how many minutes a day or
hours per week are dedicated to
consuming information right it's
probably a hundred percent or close to
100
what would it look like just imagine the
possibility that you could shift 10
of that
over here to the other column which is
creating things out of the information
you consume
just try it i don't know maybe you won't
like it maybe you'll decide you know
what thiago i i'm fine just you know
consuming this stuff but if you find
that you start to have benefits you like
all sorts of things i i'm willing to bet
are going to happen you will feel more
confident in what you consume and what
you know you'll start to make
connections with people as you share
these things you're creating
you will develop your own ideas and your
own ways of thinking about this content
all these things will start to arise and
if that happens just keep shifting hours
from the first column to the second
column i feel like at this point i spend
probably 70 or 80 percent of my time
creating things it's like i already know
enough
i've read a lot of books
i only need to consume a little bit just
to keep my ideas circulating and mostly
i just want to produce things that are
going to benefit others that is kind of
like a macro version of what we were
talking about earlier on you know you
learn the foundations and then you start
to implement there's a i first learned
it in uh atomic habits but i'm gonna
guess it's probably uh commonly held
productivity wisdom in your world uh the
explore exploit
spectrum and
the
for the people that aren't familiar
basically that when you first begin out
pretty much doing anything but
especially in a career or in a life the
goal is to explore more than you exploit
so you don't actually know what you're
good at or what's going to be effective
for you or strategies and tools and
stuff and then over time you're supposed
to begin to discriminate more towards
exploit i.e you go narrow and deep on a
few things that you know have the
highest points of leverage and then you
continue to move through there
that is something that's very attractive
to me because there is a never good
enough
sensation there is a a feeling in the
back of a lot of people's minds that
they're not ready and even if they start
to create and start to see success that
there's still
some sense of lack and i think that
after a while just knowing look i have
enough minimum viable
information to get me through and here's
the here's the big thing
execution is so much more rare than
planning is
the vast majority of people on the
internet are people that plan and
pontificate and talk and make make ideas
but don't actually end up executing
there's this interesting statistic
around the fact that planning is among
the top 10 words across all of linkedin
bios and execution doesn't even make the
top 100.
so what does that tell us it tells us
that people are discriminating toward
those that can
have good ideas but you know if planning
is the
numerator or if if planning is the
constant then execution is the
multiplier right and um you have this
great tweet a while ago man and i
must have quoted it
so many times um a paradoxical
paradoxical thing about people who
consistently choose the most high
leverage activity is their efforts have
a rough-edged half-assed quality because
polishing things to perfection is a low
leverage activity and someone replied
someone replied some guy out of nowhere
that said perfectionism is a nice way to
hide from shipping at a pace necessary
to find what works
um
i hadn't seen that reply that's really
seriously good yeah it's really true
wow yeah you touched on a few really
profound things explore and exploit my
version of that
that word exploit is not very uh not
very very politically correct these days
so i prefer
divergence and convergence
which is the same thing it's just you
need to be exposed to all the options
and then you need to choose one and give
everything
go into that option
and gosh
this is a deep concept you see
failures on both sides people not
exploring enough
or not exploiting enough or cycling back
and forth between those two often or not
realizing when it's time to transition
from one to the next
right and i think the crazy thing is
like in the past only like ceos of like
big corporations needed to think about
this right or like generals right like
army people now each one of us
is faced with such a vast array of
opportunities we have the agency and the
necessity to choose among them so it's
like we now have to think at this
extremely high level strategic
uh you know level in a way that just
wasn't our parents just didn't have to
do
yeah man and i think as well that what
that leads people to do is to continue
to explore right it drills them into a
constant scouting mentality and that's
where the
uh perfectionism is procrastination
masquerading as quality control thing
comes in that look
you you need to just get to a stage
where you start shipping work and the
difference between putting something
putting two things out at 95 or one
thing out at 99 you're going to be able
to do them with the same amount of work
and time because to get from 95 to 99 is
basically impossible or it's a huge huge
lift but you're going to learn so much
more i'm sure that you're familiar with
that study that a university professor
did where he got students it was a
photography class and he got students to
take a ton of photos and one set of
students worked for the entire semester
on a single photo and the rest of them
were just told to take as many photos as
possible and then submit one at the end
and the students that lo and behold had
taken a [ __ ] on the photos ended up
having the best work because they'd
iterated right they'd learned what
worked and what didn't
fascinating wow yeah that's that's i
think very that's it that's the
principle
what's a commonplace book
commonplace book is the
the analog forerunner of what i'm trying
to do
uh i'm a big student of history i read
the only genre that i read more of than
history is science fiction so basically
i only read about the far future or the
far past
i'm i'm i i have this this series of
tweets where i joke that presence is
overrated like the present time is like
it's so limited there's only one present
but infinite past and infinite futures
i made all the uh the buddhist buddhist
twitter crowd mad
[Laughter]
but yeah i just when i can find a
parallel in history for anything i'm
just ten times more confident in it i
don't think there's anything new under
the sun really it's just repeated
where did you first hear about a
commonplace book
yeah i think i first heard i don't
remember exactly it's been out there's
been mention of it you know on the
internet for some time uh but getting
really going back to the source and
studying it it reoccurs throughout
history
especially during times of unusual
change and uncertainty
and times where things are really where
there's sort of like some revolution
right like the enlightenment the
renaissance uh
antiquity
ancient greek times it's like when there
was basically too much information
information overload at various points
throughout history someone or some
people said hey let's just get the parts
that matter put them in one usually book
and then this will be our guide and our
reference and our roadmap
for what to do next
any famous people from history that you
found that had commonplace books
i mean so many it's almost like who
didn't i mean
john locke is a famous one uh john
milton the the english
writer
a lot of english people out of french i
think mostly we know about the european
examples the most but i also found
examples across different cultures in
china they had something similar in
japan
and poland
and a few other places uh
i can't think of a lot of specific names
but it's it's really funny it's almost
like
there's this secret undercurrent
through intellectual history
that only pops up here and there because
in most cases these great thinkers and
artists
they either
were embarrassed by this kind of
underlying creative process that they'll
be like oh that's just something i do i
just
it's kind of embarrassing i just write
little scraps of paper and and put them
in the drawer next to my bed or they
actually don't even see it it's kind of
invisible to them right it's like just
an invisible part of their process
so i've i've tried i've written some
posts on my blog and tried to kind of
surface these examples but
a lot of great a lot of great examples
from throughout history that's a really
interesting thing to talk about the fact
that the people who are at the absolute
peak of their craft are often the ones
that are either
far too aware or far too unaware of the
way that they get to it and obviously
what you've had over the last whatever
five to ten years has been this huge
proliferation of creators that actually
deconstruct these sort of structures you
know people like you or maybe an ali
abdul or someone like that who their job
is to look at it with a real
fine-grained sort of tooth comb but the
reverse is also true as well and what
what you really want is to try and find
someone who was unbelievably effective
but had no idea what their system was
those are the people that you want i
don't know like a
a productivity anthropologist or
something to go and study in the wild
these people who are unbelievably
efficient because
by design a lot of the people that are
productivity-minded and are using
productivity-style tools in a um
conscious way are all using the same
tools right no one's really
experimenting that much because they go
and watch some of your stuff or ali's
stuff or david stuff or whatever and
they
come up with their own
version of that
who are the people that did you know the
patient zeros of the productivity
movement
yeah you know i've noticed this too is
yeah this is really this is really a
missing piece there's really a gap kind
of in the market
um
often
i'll listen to interviews by like the
most well-known people like the most
famous actors writers directors whatever
it is
and they say these things these little
trite truism cliches
you know like even cl like courses i've
taken on masterclass like what what does
that show the authors the author or the
actors studio these kind of like kind of
pretty in-depth things and then they'll
say like well what's your secret oh you
just gotta you know keep persisting and
endure until the end it's like okay
these are these are quotes for hallmark
cards
but i i also can't blame them because
they literally don't remember
they do not remember
not only do they are they not aware of
what they do now because it becomes
completely unconscious but do you
remember what your creative process was
like or or any detail of it from 10
years ago like slightly no you'd be it's
impossible and so they're they they want
to give something to the audience and
they want to provide something but
they're basically just tossing off
something from the top of their head
that they know is going to get ah from
the audience and i'm just like this has
to change we need like you said to
become an anthropologist look at people
who are maybe just beginning now by the
way they might not be those super
impressive celebrities like people maybe
just ahead of you just a couple steps
down the path deconstruct what they do
you know we just did a
last week published a youtube video on
our channel deconstructing ali
abdullah's process it's funny that you
mention him it's our most popular
youtube video ever and it's because of
this like even ali was like oh i didn't
realize i did it this way and his team
is like oh we didn't realize this
happened and then all his subscribers
were like wow i never realized it's like
it's news to everyone
that's a it's interesting that you could
say it's maybe even useful to the person
that you're studying but yeah man i mean
the
i had danny trejo you know danny trejo
the hollywood superstar he was on the
show last year
and he i was asking him because
obviously he'd been to jail a bunch and
he definitely was not a trained actor
for the film actors guild
and i was asking him about the sort of
advice that he'd been given
about acting
and there was a scene that he had to do
where he had to walk in sit down and
pick up a glass of water and drink it
and
the piece of advice was you don't act
like you're going into the room to sit
down to pick up the glass of water and
you drink it you just go into the room
pick up the glass of water sit down and
you drink it i'm like
i understand that to you that makes
sense certainly but to us that sounds
like someone that has a mental problem
like that it sounds like insanity so i i
i do think there's something there
before we move on what
give me your
five
most recommended sci-fi books
i mean i have a list on my blog of over
a hundred that i've read don't want that
don't want that one the five most
recommended
i might have to look it up though but
just do off the top of your head i don't
want i don't want the reference i want
the ones that come to front of mind yeah
my my first brain is quite feeble i have
to admit um
hilariously your first brain's atrophied
because it's so [ __ ] externalized
it's so atrophied man i'm telling you
my wife is often like
thiago you you can't do without a second
brain anymore
okay it is the buttress that holds you
up now it is it is so some of the ones
that come to mind i think my favorite of
all time is hyperion
it's apparent i think it's dan simmons
it's being made into a tv show right now
um
let's see ah
lilith's brood by octavia butler was a
real a big favorite exploring more of
the biological side of science fiction
instead of technology so much
uh and then you know some of the
classics really are the best ender's
game
uh
ready player one is a newer one
obviously dune obviously the asimov
series like i didn't i didn't want to
believe that the the best ones were the
mainstream ones they're the the most
cited ones but
science fiction
yeah you kind of need to read the
classics they really are kind of the
best ones
give me your understanding of the
relationship between productivity and
creativity because i had chris bailey
that wrote hyperfocus on the show he
gave me a very interesting understanding
of this i'm i'm keen to find out your
thoughts as well
yeah for me they're just two sides of
the same coin
the two sides are the same coin they
complement each other they need each
other
uh you can just imagine someone with a
hundred percent creativity and no
productivity zero percent productivity
they might have the most brilliant
imagination and ideas and no one would
ever know and it won't ever matter
because not one piece of work will be
finished
and then you have someone say full
productivity no creativity they're
basically a machine just churning out
identical widgets
so i think you know productivity is
about getting it done creativity is
about getting it right
and you have to sort of oscillate and
and cycle between those or for like we
were saying with explore and exploit in
a given situation or at a given moment
which one do is this a a situation for
productivity or is it a situation for
creativity
i love that i really love the idea of
of moving between the two and this is
something that chris taught me as well
when he came on the show about how if
you look at an artist's work room it's
very messy there's cigarette ends and
paints and
open cans of stuff all over the
what is that doing it's engendering a
an atmosphere of creativity now if that
was the environment in which that person
tried to submit their tax returns it's
probably going to be suboptimal they
want to go somewhere which really sort
of infuses them with okay this is kind
of structured and clean and rigid
uh and
there was never a point there was almost
never a point where i'd presumed that i
would actually want less focus and less
creative less productivity i always
presumed that just pressing harder on
the pedal of productivity was the
solution to pretty much everything
but it's not and i think that
alex hormozy has this great little
aphorism where he says beginners
overvalue thinking and undervalue doing
advanced people do the opposite
and that again what we're talking about
is getting from the tools that get you
from naught to 50 and not the same ones
that are going to get you from 50 to 100
the explore and exploit paradigm is part
of this the productivity and creativity
is part of this the thinking and doing
is part of this and
this is
something else maybe that we're seeing
in the productivity space is everybody
grows up and
you get kids and yeah and you know like
ali starts a business and and david gets
a girlfriend and stuff like we're
starting to see as people grow up their
requirements in life and the insights
that they get from their productivity
tools change as well
oh yeah that's been fascinating for me
to see is like just like you were saying
my cohort the people that i'm you know
learning and growing with going through
these life stages
and suddenly the work has to change the
advice they the advice that i give has
radically changed like i have probably a
quarter
or less of the free time that i had
three years ago when we last talked
right i have since then i i got married
bought a house had a kid have a second
kid on the way got a dog two cars like
like how if i'm giving this shilling the
same advice as three years ago i'm off
my rocker it has to change but then of
course part of that is your audience
growing up with you
which is natural but then this creates
the entry point for the new generation
which we're just starting to see
you know which is so exciting dude gen z
productivity is going to suck
don't don't try and be diplomatic about
it gen z productivity is going to suck
dick what are they going to do they're
gonna tell you how to swipe through tick
tock faster not about that okay right so
workflow of building a second brain high
level it's this code um
the
what is it not an aphorism
not a methodology
when you break something down oh acronym
acronym thank you god my first brain's
wrecked as well
take us through code c is first
yeah um so this is basically the
creative process in my in my view in my
opinion
um capturing just refers to writing
things down
i mean this has been
a necessity for hundreds if not
thousands of years uh there's a mountain
of evidence that once you externalize
you have a thought an idea a theory a
prediction you write it down
all these things happen you gain
objectivity you gain distance you can
start to work with it you can start to
improve it you can start to
share it with others and get their
feedback externalizing your ideas is
fundamental the only thing that i'm
saying is new is
just in the past few years digital notes
apps alongside mobile devices and
software in general has reached a point
i think the
the balance of power with paper has
shifted
then now it is worth and justifiable to
take it digital in the first place
rather than write it down on paper and
then try to digitize it later
how should people choose what they
should capture as opposed to just
ruthlessly indexing everything
yes this is one of those things i think
it people might just need to go through
a phase of hoarding
because nothing that i can say
seems to sink in until they have over
collected way too much crap
you know and are are doing the digital
equivalent of like standing in their
living room with like so many mountain
piles of things and stuff that they
can't even walk through their house
um and it's fine actually in fact
there's even like a life like speaking
of life stages when i was in my early 20
all through my 20s i was collecting
just everything i was just exploring
right i was just taking so much in
now i'm in my mid late 30s and it's like
okay i have 7 000 notes
7 000 notes that i have in like not on
mass but individually curated and saved
so it's like okay i'm gonna i'm reading
an article or something there's a new
idea okay
it's like i could take a note on this
but is this this note really gonna be
the thing that like makes the difference
or should i just like capitalize on
these seven thousand notes over here
so i think people just need to
learn like tr like try capturing
everything but then i think what you
eventually get to is being far more
picky far more discerning like you said
and the best rule of thumb that i know
is
to save something that resonates with
you say something that moves you like on
a somatic
intuitive emotional level
is the best
rule of thumb that i've encountered for
deciding what to save
there's a idea from tim ferriss called
the good [ __ ] sticks yes and that has
been now this might be a cope for me
because i don't have a particularly
efficient personal knowledge management
system you'll be episode
500 and something in four years of this
show i'm just looking at my apple notes
which is what i use
2247 notes
and
i don't know whether it is a cope but
certainly for me just allowing the stuff
that
really really does make me think holy sh
i can't not write that down that's the
threshold now my threshold probably
could and should be a little bit lower
than that it probably there probably are
ideas that i've read that i valued that
i've let go
but
my requirements given the amount that i
have to put out on the show three
episodes a week three clips a week
interviews and guesting that i do on
other shows other projects and things
that i have going on outside of that
the
uh
availability for space in terms of
demand
has to be matched by the supply in terms
of what i'm prepared to put into it and
for me the
i'll probably have sent it to other
people on whatsapp i'll have probably
taken a photo of whatever it is and gone
dude this is unbelievable or i've linked
it to a few friends
and then i'll go oh yeah i probably
should
i probably should make that going so
again there i mean is that an acceptable
solution for you do you think if
somebody has got a high overwhelm of
information and not much time
yeah raise the threshold
you know there's a couple beliefs i have
that are kind of metaphysical and that i
can't exactly prove but
for some reason
have really helped me with this
maybe someone out there can find some
science to back this up i i
embrace confirmation bias i come up with
hair brain ideas and then i try to look
for evidence that
but um one of them is that kind of what
you're saying with the good [ __ ] sticks
that your life is convergent
i think we tend to think our our lives
especially those of us interested in
many things with many pursuits many
curiosities we think life is constantly
leading us on this wild goose chase
divergent thing
and i i guess i've just chosen to
believe i think life tends to be
convergent
and almost in a sense like you have a
destiny like there's certain
interests and people and opportunities
and just
pathways that keep arising again and
again it's almost like reality is like
hey
like we want this it's inviting you it
wants you to go down this path just
because of your nature your personality
your your background your history your
genetics
so
if i just believe that reality is
convergent it's almost like i only take
it a threshold that i sometimes use is i
only take a note of an idea if it's
tracked me down
and demanded that i pay attention to it
multiple times
like only on the third or fourth
encounter when it's like
you know banging on my door and being
like take note of me then i'll be like
okay fine clearly reality is trying to
tell me something that this is important
to me
um and then the other the other one is
that reality is fractal
this is something i i think i think
there's probably science to this but
it's like patterns tend to be repeated
at all scales
so like your life has a pattern that
same pattern is repeated at the scale of
a decade of your life it's also repeated
on the scale of a year it's repeated in
each relationship it's like the way that
you do one thing is the way you do
everything and so there's a kind of
recurring fractal pattern in your life
which if that's true it means you can
only have to pay attention to one level
like there's principles that you want to
discover but the same principle is
probably visible from the way you do
laundry to the way you organize your
computer to the way you organize your
room to the way you organize your
priorities to the way you organize your
relationships it's like you only need to
find the pattern at one level and that
whole stack gets unlocked for you this
is something i've never mentioned on any
podcast because it's like really out
there but those are two kind of uh kind
of hypotheses that i have bro i am 100
in with you here and i don't i don't
adhere to the sort of woo metaphysical
horse [ __ ] that much
i i fell in love with um ammo fatty
right with sort of the love of fate and
i really fell in love with that over the
last couple of years because i started
to see these consistent themes come up
in my life and obviously you're the
common denominator between all of the
experiences that you have right
all of my exes are
bitter resentful [ __ ] it's like what
all of them
all of them
well what do they have in common
other than the fact that they were in a
relationship with you
nothing so either you're selecting them
or you're causing them to be this way
and yeah
just
realizing i had this idea that i believe
that most people's outcomes in life are
going to occur no matter how much
neuroses they apply to them that all of
the anxiety and all of the worry and all
of the concern and the negative thought
loops and the staying awake at night
i think at most at most
nets you about an extra 10
in terms of the outcomes that you can
get in life so
another way to look at that would be to
say well
for the cost of perhaps between 5 and 10
of my outcomes in life i could get rid
of almost all of my anxiety and neuroses
and thoughtless and concerned in
sleepless nights
okay so
what would my life be like
if i
if i believed that my destiny was my
destiny to have what would my life be
like if i already knew that the success
or the family or the financial
aspirations or whatever if if that was
there
what would just imagine what it would be
like if i knew that the outcome was
predestined
how would i behave how would that change
my daily experience of the things and
the challenges and the concerns and the
worries and stuff that i have and that i
think maps a little bit onto the the
fractal stuff things at many levels
right i've seen this it's arisen a bunch
of different times it's banging on the
door saying hey idiot you need to you
need to take notice of this it's
occurred in the gym and in my health and
in my relationship with my parents and
you go
right okay i'm sorry yeah that's an
error for me i'll i will do better next
time and you do and then that's one of
the principles that you need to keep a
hold of but um yeah man i'm 100
uh with you on that the two
uh
borderline autistic people that love
productivity talking about the woo
metaphysics delivering the life
direction
in the universe
yeah it's it's it's kind of the the
exact opposite of the idea of
self-improvement
but i kind of i think every the opposite
of every great truth is also true so
like yeah it's you can transform your
life for sure you can change anything
and
most things are pretty much you know
kind of
not predestined but they're just the
natural consequence of cause and effect
the future is unfolding mostly based on
the past i think it's psychologically
healthy honestly
well that's a that's a really good point
the fact that it is an opposite
what does it mean that
i believe so much in personal
sovereignty and agency and living your
life by design not by default
and yet at the same time i'm saying that
most of the outcomes that you get in
life are probably going to occur no
matter what you do
uh
i'm not really too sure how i how i
square that circle and yet i believe
that both of those things are true at
the same time maybe that's cognitive
dissonance i'm not too sure or maybe
it's a cope but it it genuinely seems to
be true it seems to be true to me that
the people that are good end up getting
good results i mean
uh charlie munger's got that um
no sorry it's naval that says you don't
need uh
spiritual energy to deliver karma to you
karma is just you repeating your habits
and patterns over and over until the
world gives you what you deserve
whoa
there it is you know like that that is
what it is are you the sort of person
that continues to work hard okay could
you be working a bit more harder and a
bit more efficient and a bit more
productive or whatever yeah probably but
the fundamental code right the
foundation the base layer that you're
writing upon is the fact that you're
somebody that works hard and seeks out
opportunities and is personable or nice
or polite or giving or a team player has
humor or whatever right like the traits
don't matter as much as the attribute my
dad my dad is not uh
an aphoristic sort of guy but yours used
to say that form is temporary but class
is permanent and it was the fact that
the
long-held attributes that you have will
end up winning over time whereas the the
the individual fluctuations in the
market the noise doesn't doesn't matter
as much as the signal
i think it depends a lot on the person
too some there's a lot of people out in
the world
who could just use more agency who could
just
could use dialing up the belief that
they can change things other people it
needs to be dialed down yes some people
are just wailing on
something thinking let me just knock
down this
you know impregnable you know fortress
and they could they could honestly
probably it sounds weird to say but use
less agency bro i've got jocker willing
coming on the show this week um and
i'm gonna ask him about this because
extreme ownership right is his idea he's
all about radical personal
responsibility and i want to ask him
is it possible to take too much
responsibility what happens when you
begin to take responsibility for things
which aren't your responsibility well
that's part of perhaps the the the um
acknowledgement that you are able to
step in and change things maybe that's a
part of a masculine role as a man to be
able to hoist the heaviest weight that
you can find and carry it and such like
and i go well yeah but after a while you
actually end up
realizing you're not netting
any benefit by doing this it's actually
probably making you less effective and
efficient so i'm really
really interested to find out what what
he uh what he says there okay so me too
someone's someone's captured whatever it
is they've got a note-taking app they've
put it down somewhere next up what do
they do
so
after you capture for a while it starts
to pile up
and you start to realize okay uh search
is powerful but not someday maybe it
will be adequate we won't have to
organize anything
but for for now you need to add some
kind of order some kind of structure
and i have a
approach to this it's called para which
is probably the most single most popular
technique that i've ever
talked about or written about or
mentioned
which i think the the main principle
there is instead of organizing as if
you're a library according to these
broad academic subjects you know
business
psychology
you know botany as if you're trying to
you know create a university you should
this is personal knowledge management
you should organize according to your
projects and your goals
that's why it's worth putting in all
this effort is to move forward your
projects achieve your goals and so pera
is basically about organizing content
according to how actionable it is and
when it's going to be actionable
um how do you not get lost in organizing
you've got you know
progressive summarization and and stuff
like that is a another tool that you use
how do people if they haven't got uh
caught up over indexing everything how
do they not get caught up over
organizing everything
yeah it's like each step of code has its
own benefits and its own pitfalls
right
you can definitely there's traps all
along the way
um i think for me it's the fact that
there's only four categories
that's it these are
big buckets
right it's like
for a physical analogy it's less like a
filing cabinet where it's like okay
where's the exact right little place for
this to go it's more like you know
imagine you're decluttering your garage
you just have four giant buckets
and it's just like this is important now
this will be important later
this
might be important at some time and this
is not important it's like these very
clear cut just like
uh kind of simple decisions
that you only have to make one decision
unlike tagging by the way tagging you
have to like tag all the things that
could be related to all the things that
connect it's one decision you make it
one time
you take one action related to that
decision and you're done
when it comes to distilling just mention
there about progressive summarization uh
what do you think most people get wrong
when it comes to distilling and
progressive summarization as well
yeah so this is the third letter the d
for distill
i think the main thing and i talk about
this in the book
um
we seriously underestimate how sensitive
we are to the way that information is
presented
the way the format the visual look uh
you know if you're familiar anyone who's
familiar with web design
gets exposure to this you change one
little headline the color of a button
the spacing the the
shade these my new differences can
easily produce
double-digit you know changes in how
many people click how many people stay
on the page how many people take action
so it's like we've realized this in the
public sphere but then in the private
sphere
it's just
looks awful like any note-taking you see
except like notion is the big exception
is just so badly designed it's like this
ugly text that is all bunched up
together everything looks like it was
designed by engineers because it was
and so progressive summarization is
really just one way of
paying attention to the visual
interaction
can you look and see just the title of a
note and instantly grasp at least what
it's about approximately if you decide
it's relevant to you can you scroll down
and see
one or two or three highlighted passages
that tell you in a glance what is the
main takeaway what is the main point
what is this trying to say and if you
decide it's still relevant you have all
the other details right there in the
surrounding note that's that's what it
is it's it's the ability to perceive
something quickly with little energy and
then immediately be able to take action
on it so is that your job now to give
your future self a gift of a
well-distilled
progressively summarized document that
reduces everything down to their most
component parts that's right that's
right
there was this you mentioned there about
uh the changes that you can do in ux and
web design i got this statistic from
seth stevens davidowitz his new book a
designer famously quit google because it
frequently ignored the intuition of
trained designers in favor of data the
final straw for the designer was an
experiment that tested 41 shades of blue
on an ad link on gmail to collect data
on which one would lead to the most
clicks the designer may have been
frustrated but the data experiment
netted google an estimated 200 million
dollars per year in additional revenue
that is cr i think i've heard of this
that is an insane story
i love that stuff man okay so we've
distilled stuff down we've progressively
summarized the final the final step e
yeah so this is the it's the finale it's
the last one i think the most important
one like
you know the question always in the back
of people's minds especially as they get
into the weeds of this is like why
why am i doing all this for for what for
what purpose
and i think it ultimately comes down to
self-expression
you know we're all as knowledge workers
today professional communicators
like isn't that what we're doing all day
we're communicating through through all
these different means and channels with
various people
i mean we live in a
communication-centric world and you have
something inside of you maybe it's your
story it's a message it's ideas its
opinions decisions
that you basically all the all the
outcomes you're trying to create in your
life depend on your ability to
communicate what what that is inside of
you in a way that's succinct
that is well supported and credible
that is compelling that people want to
pay attention to and ultimately that
they want to act on
that's self-expression is the purpose to
create a second brain what if people say
well i don't have a blog or a podcast or
a sub stack
where can i express my ideas i'm just a
a curious person
yeah this is a common thing people say i
think
probably because they see me as an
online content creator and many of my
examples and kind of anecdotes are based
on that
but i would just push back on the idea
that anyone is not a creator
you know i have this definition of being
a creator that i love which is to bring
something true
good or beautiful into the world
to bring something that is true
factual scientific
effective that is good
a story a truth some meaning a
relationship
or beautiful
right like inspiring
aesthetically pleasing all that stuff
by that standard
i mean when you host a dinner party
you're being a creator when you you know
make a schedule for your kids summer
you're being a creator when you lobby
your local city council for funding for
the part local park you're being a
creator
it's funny i have a lot of these like
suburban examples of like being a
suburban dad because that's how i'm
creating a lot these days but
even those kind of mundane everyday
things are very informationally
intensive i mean to vote in your local
elections the amount of of information
that i had to make sense of to just even
understand who the candidates were i
mean to plan a vacation is practically a
you know a part-time job in some cases
um i mean even to get together with my
friends to get together with your
friends in your 30s is like a serious
project
[Laughter]
i suppose as well one thing that almost
the vast majority of people are going to
have is maybe raising a kid so you find
out that you and your partner are
pregnant and that you're going to
you've got eight months okay
i don't know how babies work
how do they work and what do we need for
the the room and
should we go for a wireless or a wired
in
detective for the cctv and you know
all of those things um
that
that is the most
normal solution or the most normal
requirement sorry that i could think of
for someone needing to express on the
other side you're going to go through
all of these different review sites and
youtubes
giving you the different details about
is it a pull out caught from the side of
the bed or is it a fixed cot that goes
on the edge of the bed is it yeah
whatever whatever this is not from
personal experience this is my business
partner me uh vicariously living the
pain of his three kids through him um
going back to one thing that i can see
as a potential stumbling block for
people when they start to index this
information um discoverability
trying to so there for me to find the
study from seth stevens to vidowitz i
had to search google now i just put
google in and thankfully i knew it was
about google and it came up but
that's probably not the most
oh i mean is that sophisticated i don't
know you tell me
yeah you know i think this is a great
filter is if there's anything that
google can find fast reliably
just depend on google for it
right like you know
these sort of factual questions and
answers you know what is the population
of france
you know what year did this book come
out uh when was this historical figure
born these kind of things that you will
you will instantly with one search top
result find the answer don't use your
precious
human you know manual time and attention
to save those in your second brain
what's the point
yeah so what i thought what can google
not find is first of all feelings
you can google the answer to a question
but you can't google a feeling
right this comes back to why you should
capture things that move you
images stories metaphors
uh
you know
songs music paintings
things that you can't just do you know
you can't do a google search oh a
an image that's going to inspire me in
exactly this way uh things that are
filtered to your experience right like
lessons you hard-won lessons you learn
from making that mistake
making that error or you learn from a
mentor or you learn from a colleague
things that maybe everyone knows them or
a lot of people know them but will have
a special resonance for you because it
was through your experience
um i think you should not try to compete
with google they're going to they're
going to
they're going to win those use cases but
fill in the gaps basically with your
your second brain
what tools do people need or what tools
do you use
to get this moving
you know the sec the central one is a is
a digital notes app
digital notes apps are the best by far
the best you can actually implement a
second brain in all sorts of different
systems
but i think what's important about
digital notes apps is they're ubiquitous
you can have them on your computer on
your tablet on your smartphone on your
watch and soon on your glasses
they're just everywhere uh they're
casual this is the key thing right some
people sometimes people want to have
like a database with this very precise
data entry procedure and all these you
know fields
note-taking the whole reason note-taking
is powerful is that it's messy
it's spontaneous it is chaotic it
doesn't follow its free form right and
digital notes apps are almost like the
only category of software that is that
way software doesn't tend to be free
form
right you want that kind of open canvas
and they're free
you know you don't need to pay anything
use apple notes or android whatever the
android equivalent is on your phone use
evernote which has a free tier use
simple note uh most of these apps if not
all of them have a free option start
there you know it's like don't don't
don't even com this is the thing it's
like maybe this isn't for you
i'm not saying digital note-taking is
the answer to everyone and all their
problems it might be just an answer for
some people for some kinds of problems
just test it out using a free app on
your phone
and if it's successful just take it from
there
if it wasn't for the fact that you were
so heavily
already invested into evernote
would you have moved across to something
else or is this are you grandfathered in
with evernote or would you be tempted by
notion if you were starting again
yeah it's a good question so it's funny
i've already migrated a couple times i
started originally on microsoft word if
you can believe it then google docs then
evernote
so my expectation i mean no technology
lives forever right there's generations
that mature and then kind of pass away
um i i'm sure at some point or another
i'm gonna have to move on from evernote
it's gonna be it's gonna get shut down
it's gonna be acquired it's gonna become
obsolete
um i've been testing obsidian
obsidian because there's this kind of
newest wave of very sexy very trendy
apps
sometimes called networked thinking apps
or link based apps like the three main
ones are rome obsidian and log seek
that people are just raving about
they're crazy about them
they
oh man it's really hard to summarize but
basically it's a completely new paradigm
for personal knowledge management it's
instead of being based on a hierarchy
folders within folders within folders
it's based on a graph much like the
internet
right it's not an incremental
improvement it's a completely different
paradigm
but from what i've seen it has a long
way to go
i mean i was using obsidian took me two
hours of intense troubleshooting to
figure out how to sync this note that i
just took on my phone to my computer and
i'm a you know reasonably tech savvy
person
like i tend to wait until a technology
is mature it's it's been around for 10
years
so around like 20 30 i think i should be
adopting the new paradigm of notes apps
that's funny so one thing that i wish
i'm an avid apple notes user i've tried
and there's some stuff that have gone in
that's gone in evernote there's some
stuff which goes in notion um
the only things that i would bring
across to apple notes
if i could right now
would be
linking notes within notes i think that
the ability of notion to do that where
you can nest kind of visually and you
can hyperlink is phenomenal
that's very very intuitive and makes an
awful lot of sense and toggles being
able to snap
bunches of batches of text closed so
that you can just display things in a
neater way but apple notes is not far
off man i mean for a kind of the most
simple use case it's absolutely rapid if
you're typing on your phone as soon as
you press return you'll see it appear on
the screen in front of you on your
laptop it's really really good and i
think that there's some updates coming
with ios 16 which looks pretty cool and
if they can get anywhere close to those
functions that i've just mentioned there
i think it's i think there'll be no
reason for me to change at least not yet
i would start this is what i i recommend
to people start with the default
pre-installed notes app
really because it's like with this whole
practice the main thing is whether you
do it or you don't
right doing it in any degree to any
capacity with whatever standard
will
give you most of the benefits whereas
not doing it will give you none this is
why it's so important that it be
frictionless what frictionlessness does
is it helps you cross over from the
doing nothing to doing something the
zero to one right
and if you need the pre the built-in
notes up on your phone to do that then
you know more power to you i think it's
perfect
what are five of your most used apps
when it comes to your
either daily productivity or even
entertainment stuff what are the things
that you rely on the most in terms of
apps
yeah you know there's kind of a basic
tool kit
i wrote about these in in a blog post on
getting to inbox zero but there's kind
of this like very it's almost like you
buy a toolkit and it has like a hammer a
screwdriver there's like five things
that if it doesn't have that you're like
what the heck
it's like my
to-do list app which is things
which i've used for 10 years
it's my
notes app which is evernote also been on
there for 10 years it's my relator app
instapaper i think i've been on there
six or seven years
uh it is my calendar app i use one
called busycal which is just basically a
client for google calendar
uh and then it's the email app
superhuman
those five are like my world they're
they're as second nature to me as like
my my
my arms and my legs i like don't think
about them i just like operate them as
like an extension of my nervous system
convince me on busy cal and superhuman
because i have a lot of calendar
problems and a lot of email problems
yeah so let's see busy cal i just love
that i never have to think about it it's
calendaring is this funny thing
it's kind of
ironically timeless um for a while i was
using uh woven which was this like up
and coming new very sexy thing of course
like all up and coming trendy
productivity apps got acquired or
something got shut down i'm like this
always happens this is why i hate
adopting new tech
um busy cal it's just made you can tell
by just like very nuts and bolts
designers and engineers just trying to
solve like you know these little mundane
like just stupid problems like when you
invite someone to a calendar entry and
then you move it to a different day does
it like resend something like little
things like that that just make your
life like just better
um
and i just never have to think about it
just does its job that's that's the
pitch okay superhuman
yeah so superhuman is a bit harder
because it's you know kind of expensive
for a productivity app i mean
i'm a little bit biased here because
the founder of superhuman
uh he told me that my article on
reaching inbox zero was one of the
inspirations for the product
he said they get that article they they
send it to every new hire as like this
is our philosophy so when he told me
that and then i started using the
software's like okay this is if someone
just custom designed an email app for me
because they kind of did
so i was i was helpless the the the
sales pitch was i couldn't turn it down
and so it just it just makes the pros
basically what superhuman does is it
makes the process of clearing your email
into the most hyper efficient
get it done
go from the top to the bottom process
you can imagine versus how most people
use email which is as a combined crm
task management system reminder system
note-taking system to-do list all these
things it just is hyper focused on that
one use case
give me
five uh physical items as well that you
don't think that you could live without
oh five physical items um i mean a paper
notebook
people are surprised to hear this but
there's certain situations such as
conversations when i'm meeting with
someone on purpose in person i tend to
take physical notes because i've just
found having a device is distracting
uh let's see what else my trusty
hydroflask water bottle
essential wide mouth so that i can get
ice in there
this like two or three x's my water
consumption each day
uh let's see what else what about the
chair what chair have you decided on at
the moment i'm currently in the market
for a new office chair and i
sent ali a text the other day asking him
whether he was still with harman kardon
and he was like yeah i am but i've
changed from this thing to this thing
what are you sat on you know what's
really funny chris i when it comes to
physical things i am the furthest thing
from an optimizer
i i don't i don't get into it i don't
have a preferred chair or pen or monitor
or keyboard like ali gets into the stuff
right i have this weird thing where it's
almost like i'm so in the digital world
i have these these very specific
preferences about the digital world but
the physical world i'm kind of like
i i don't really live i live in the
world of ideas and i live in the virtual
world i barely am present here in the
physical
plane
[Laughter]
yes that's that that kind of rings true
as well so let's say that someone sort
of likes the idea of this but thinks
look i've already gone through the
process of having to read a book um that
was fairly effortful
and i'm concerned about extra effort on
the back end of going through and taking
notes and progressive summarization and
all of this stuff
what are the most important things of
making this whole process or
productivity overall
less effortful do you think
i think it's giving yourself permission
to do what you like
just move toward what excites you move
toward what moves you
um this is a this is a deep it's it's
funny i teach this course this
intensive four-week program you know all
this all all this material and honestly
i think it's mostly about unlearning not
so much about learning like i take
people through this process they have to
unlearn everything they know about
note-taking which is all based in school
and all the problems that come with that
all the baggage it's what they learned
at work
in corporations which is a whole other
set of baggage it's what they learned
from their parents
right and what we tend to learn from all
these external authorities is what you
care about doesn't matter
what you find interesting is probably
not important
you need to spend your time and
attention on things that someone else
has said are important
it's like we're just systematically
brainwashed into ignoring our feelings
our desires what gives us pleasure what
excites our curiosity and a lot of being
successful in this is relearning that
you know that you do sound like miyamoto
musashi or something at the moment
you're like this sort of old zen master
that's
been away in a cave on the top but i i
genuinely do agree and there's elements
you know especially talking about the um
repeating themes that you see that kind
of spiral up and spiral down your life
at different gradients and
i definitely see this starting to come
through for me as well so i i often
wonder how many of the insights that we
get around productivity or personal
development or self-growth how many of
them are born of the efforts that we've
gone through and how many of them just
come along for the ride as a byproduct
of getting older
and i think that a big chunk of them
actually
adjust that with a little bit of a
flavoring on the top of oh well i found
this one or i developed this one for
sure the real second brain is the
the things you learn the relationships
you have the friends you made along the
way
look tiago forte ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out all of the
stuff that you do and read the blog post
that we've referenced today where should
they go
yeah you can find everything at
buildingasecondbrand.com
i love it tiago until next time man
appreciate it chris what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace